previously on bad guys hey bud I need to
stop taking this so seriously it's not a
big deal have you heard about how fun
games they're supposed to be yes they're
supposed to be fun aren't they what do
you mean well you have the crying baby
stupid baby it's it's an emo ditz me
laughs oh my god oh my god oh my god
guys never just get frustrated something
no never what are you talking about just
try it you're just trying to do
something it's like oh let's just won't
you know behave like ah man so angry no
I have no idea it's okay I'm here with
you market oh I don't want to talk about
it I'll probably be supportive I don't
know I don't know what to do for you man
all right nothing back yeah that's how
the song went
toe-tapper you know man that's sweet
sweet jazz I made it back up in the hole
this time I shall ascend beyond the tree
okay fine oh no no there I go no no stop
oh mama what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] rocket
ship your rockets attacked oh no no no
oh god no I've ruined it I've ruined my
upper dog [ __ ] I had a chance to [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that was a hell of a joke no
God please leave yes I'm [ __ ] the
momentum I had I had bill oh [ __ ]
really I move an inch and it just bumps
his body up against a [ __ ] pebble any
[ __ ] losses in all it's so goddamn
stupid it's just so stupid the way that
works how can you lose it all hello who
is it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys can tolerate my rage and so can
i I don't know how to tell you this
right now I'm having the time of my life
we are not quitting work I mean I
believe you mark it's okay
no I'm fine I'm fine I'm over it is that
is that really all I do just shut up no
happiness
no playing at your marks away mark if
your game on screen oh it's not yeah
it's not dude just hang on two hours
with him not showing the game no I
showed the game just hang on I gotta get
no stop
I just got it let me I'll be happy and
I'll be able to have fun and stuff if I
just get over this I'm down below I'm
okay I was at the treat I felt but it's
all good yes Bob homie baby how's a good
man oh my god I just did the sickest
tricks to get to where I am I'm a pirate
with a jackhammer
with leaf pants what I have my look at
me
I guess oh [ __ ] yeah I've got a glass
pogo stick now and pants dude you guys
are all this like crazy customization
when the obviously the originals like
where it's at
look I'm emo man look at my gaping mouth
I don't want to look at your gaping
mouth look at it I don't want the hearts
are really distracting [ __ ] I know right
bad that would be really annoying oh no
no no no no oh yes I made it on the
other side no no no not like this save
it I saved it
[ __ ] okay save it okay okay okay yes yes
yes I made it my man
where am I going I don't know where I'm
going be a little kotappa bud what
guys there's armadillos I'm in the land
of armadillos that's pretty cool my god
somebody just [ __ ] [ __ ] into the
sky what the [ __ ] I'm I'm playing with a
controller that disconnects itself every
minute in half I I don't know Bob you
you've got an iron will or something but
I feel better I feel better I feel now
that I've accomplished something I feel
bad I recognize that I am NOT pleasant
to be around when I'm angry I get that
it's fun no I'm gonna get that I get
that I get that but at the same time I
feel like I've taken this with dignity
and grace I just want to reiterate how
graceful and diggnation
I've been I would even say that you were
digna hrithik I was also gonna say the
exact same thing I've been making some
of the sickest moves that and go
absolutely nowhere it's just because I
absolutely refuse I refuse to let go of
this space bar it's like I don't think I
physically can anymore I think I've lost
that ability why am I getting banjo
music I felt this for many signs before
calm down game I will kill your family
calm down wait be a little more
technicians with you yeah come on it's
embarrassing for yourself wait
embarrassing for yourself and bring a
few children how to handle things the
way mark handles things somewhere come
on I went to three years but so hard he
freaking with chili yeah I'll bet
wait you make me angrier than this game
does what does that say about you as a
person I don't know that I'm great and
you have low tolerance clearly if I'm
playing Pogo stuck and I'm enjoying it I
have hella tolerance maybe you're just a
sadist for sticks oh you little [ __ ]
no it's fine it's fine I'm trying to do
this a stupid way and I don't know why
but I think it's gonna make me better in
the long run I do things that you know
sometimes can improve my skill as a
gamer Oh 69 go in the hole oh I am
needed for that yes you did unmute for
that why were you muted for that in the
first wait that sort of smut I will not
have on this penis class
Oh how long will you play this game hey
let me just get through this next
section Oh No here we go big boom I'm
the best there ever was let it be no no
what look at the tree the tree back of
the tree whoa whoa imma go I'm just
lucky to be friends with you you know
that's okay I won't forget you when I'm
at the pogo jump championships it's all
good things they're horrible things are
happening Oh horrible boy that doesn't
sound good
wave your amount is teetering it at
nineteen percent if that's good or bad
that's a girl did you not mean to come
back down here I'm back in black I stood
my crack with thoughts of you it's a
musical lyric oh God really really
really really really really really
really oh wait I see that you're behind
me again why why oh god no don't bounce
your fat ass sorry
yeah you're fast that fast
- out of here fast ass away from me no
my ass will speed where it damn well
pleases slow ass my main problem is it
gets so cold like I can be so in control
and everything oblique I can predict it
and then like everything's good and then
it's like my brain hemorrhages and
suddenly every control is written in
math and not numbers and letters it's
like it's like nothing nothing makes
sense anymore dude we've all been there
trust me yeah oh [ __ ] really raw
[ __ ] really the one the one oh my
it's it talks like the one way in King
I'm talking how the one thing that could
fail and it do you guys need to really
get get the lead out there's a lot of
what's gonna say I think you're right oh
[ __ ] oh my guys singing that's adorable
I just want you guys to know I would be
willing to come back and suffer with you
as opposed to being around the [ __ ]
that are up here because they are
insufferable they just like laughing at
you yes okay I'm making progress here we
go here we go here we go is it yes yes
oh [ __ ] oh no mark your percentage it's
not as high as it was oh [ __ ]
mikesh Abbess I had that emotion again
the emotion that caused you to choke on
your own damn it god damn this I hate it
so bad it's it's just a worse I know
dude I know you feel me
I know oh my god really oh man dude dude
where are you guys are you guys still
below the tree
I'm below the tree like a loser wait
someone's gonna [ __ ] who's cheating
they got a bungee cord
what someone just like launched up use
the cheats maybe because they've maybe
they've beaten the level before and they
get a special reward cuz I've seen them
over here hey dude wait musics playing
oh my god
that's a you're behind me that's not
what you want to see oh my god it's just
so goddamn annoying I felt so good just
a little bit ago I felt so good because
I made progress you know what I mean hey
progress is something to be proud of man
well I mean that's what I'm saying III I
was proud and now I'm not all the
feeling of that accomplishment no dashed
against the rocks nobody can take that
away from you it seems like the game is
taking that away from me actually
yeah take it away now that progress that
will live on my heart I just want ever
[Music]
over the tree jump across the chasm jump
across there's another tree it's okay if
you fall just make sure you get a super
jump you'll bounce the whole distance
back up I didn't do it well maybe you
didn't do it good enough
oh hey mom over the tree now mop that's
what we call each other
I call him mop come on
oh really oh really oh yeah - you think
that's how it's gonna be huh yeah
believe this don't know who I am I can't
believe you played this for two hours
wait and that was all the farther you I
never got to this tree before you could
just hop over that [ __ ] I'd like to
think Wade those an echoing of my
despair so thank you for letting out the
weirdest scream I uh I joined it on the
phone I just oh I just
guys we all we all just stop with your
little stupid face and your little
stupid ass I'm down Wade goddamn a
[ __ ] regular mark over here goddamn
my right mark right you right man you're
right
oh oh oh no listen don't do that I need
to let go of the thing you know that
thing you were doing mark where you
wouldn't let go
yeah I I really I did that and I never
let go it really hinders your progress
after a while it sure dude don't it so
good how am I not getting over this okay
that's good enough for me no it's not
stop I'm gonna go back to you guys
because I miss my friends I have no joy
I've just got [ __ ] just nothing but
[ __ ] up here just why why get a life
get a [ __ ] life no one cares about
who you are coming back I'm coming back
guys I'm coming back very big of you I
just I just want to be near you so I can
feel something other than pure hatred
well I'm a Viking what I don't know wait
sevens amazing you I don't want to come
back for Wade Bob I just wanna stay
straight up oh you ask you asinine troll
hey man how's it going
I was at the tree that's cool
I
I can't get back over the tree all right
I've now tricked him I've tricked him ha
I'm smarter they've all gone back ha ha
have fun with those [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm the smart one
I'm smart we've been doing this like
eight hours right proximately I just
it's like I've gotten so much worse
i I've gotten so much I thought I was
getting better and then suddenly I
realize I've actually been getting so
much worse at this game was that noise
bird flu in my room nothing
shut up it's coming out of me let me get
to you guys music is bad music for me
too I can't even fall backwards
correctly what where are you guys where
are you I've got one in JP and Patrick's
hole alright copy hey Bob hey come back
further mark okay let's go Bob
no well okay ah let's go Bob we're never
coming back to this game this game Bert
I can't guess [ __ ] I can't even go
backwards you wait wait let's hang out
by the oh my god I just want to get the
[ __ ] out of my way get oh my god I can't
even go backward there [ __ ] finally
miles an hour who are these people were
they here okay Oh done with this yeah I
think
[Music]